Today I’m absolutely delighted because
we’re learning English with the Harry Potter Reunion!
There is no doubt that the Harry Potter film and book series
has undoubtedly been a spellbinding part of everyone’s childhood.
It’s hard to believe that it’s been 20 years since the release of
the first movie and almost 25 years since the launch of the first book.
What makes this reunion so special, is that it takes us on an emotional journey
back to Hogwarts where we get to reunite with the iconic cast members,
who have brought magic to the lives of many
and have no doubt left their mark on a generation.
But before we get into this long-awaited reunion, if you’d
like to continue learning with us so that you can understand
your favorite TV series and movies without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without subtitles,
be sure to hit that subscribe button and bell down below now,
so that you never miss out on any of our new lessons.
If you’re also a huge fan of Luna Lovegood,
let us know in the comments below
if you would like us to do a
special lesson all about her.
Now let’s do a quick quiz to see how
much you’ve learned by watching the interview
without subtitles and answering some questions!
And for the super Potterheads out there,
we’ve included a question that only a
true Harry Potter fan would know.
Also, stay tuned until after the
quiz to enjoy some bonus scenes.
It's just the best, most amazing experience
in that, and I appreciated that so much.
It really is like family. We're just so intrinsically
linked. They're very important people to me.
The crew on these films were unbelievable. There are
people on these films that are foundational to who I am.
I feel so lucky to be where I am and to
have the life that I have and be able to
work with the people I work with now
but none of it is possible without this.
Um, so yeah. It was, it was a very
it was a very good 10 years.
Expecto Patronum
After all this time?
Always.
If you enjoyed this lesson and you’d like to continue
learning with Harry Potter, I definitely recommend this lesson
where you can not only see Hermione punch
Draco in the face, but you can learn useful vocabulary too!